і покаже
що ми
прая понаського
[музика]
Раду ми знаходимось на автовокзалі у
місті Тернопіль куди з Хмельницького
приїхала допомога для наших захисників
термобілизна теплі речі шкарпетки шапки
валаклави для потреб наших військових
яким зараз ці речі дуже необхідні
[музика]
[оплески]
це іспанські медикаменти прийшли і
термобілизна неможливо оцінити і
неможливо висловити наскільки ми вдячні
за допомогу нашим іноземним друзям за
надзвичайно велику кількість
медикаментів необхідних медикаментів
нашим військовим нашим
захисникам і волонтерський штаб
європейської Солідарності в місті
Полтава продовжує свою роботу Ми
продовжуємо передавати гуманітарну
допомогу тим хто цього
потребує
зараз перебуваю у Львові в одному з
найбільших пунктів збору гуманітарної
допомоги от зараз ви бачите за моєю
спиною волонтери вантажать гуманітарну
допомогу примаємось Всі разом Ми віримо
в найкраще ми мовимо за нашу армію
за наших хлопців дай Бог Ми
переможемо ми пакуємо пакунки нашим
бійцям які захищають нас на
передовій Ми повинні перемогти Воля або
смерть це буде
Україна